so you I want to get I want to talk
about your um upbringing because I had a
trumpet talk about your dad reconnecting
yeah that's really stuff from the
beginning though I can send you guys a
couple pictures actually so you can post
them if you want but so you know I grew
up um you know my dad was uh violent I
grew up in a really violent home and I
just remember like um
even in my head as a six-year-old going
I don't belong here wow I feel that yeah
yeah there's something wrong here you
know I mean I I ca I can't leave because
I'm seven and I have no money and you
know I mean but I just know that you
know me one day I'll be out of the
situation and I'll never go back so um
wow so when I read about your background
and stuff like that
um start from the beginning like
Maryland you grew up yeah I grew up in
Maryland
um through the 90s so I was born in 1990
and uh wow that's when I graduated from
high school
51. 51. yeah uh yeah and uh so yeah
black dad white mom
um I'm one of nine but I'm the only
child between my mother and my father
um and they were never married and I was
born out of wedlock and my mother uh
they were both you know addicted to
crack cocaine and various drugs alcohols
it was a big one my mother was a
prostitute at one point a lot of sexual
abuse and my sister is getting raped and
coming home and like having to deal with
all that as a child which was really
difficult
um and then yeah and then my mother she
was never really there for me because
she would drink you know she was
drinking all night she sleep all day and
then um
yeah man I I my only real Escape there
was a few of them actually
um but the biggest one was music but
that's why this is so special to me
because you're such a like a hero of
mine you know I actually was talking to
Jamie Kennedy about this because when I
was surrounded by you know drugs and
murderers in the household and just the
craziest [__]
you made me laugh
oh man you know it's a real thing though
so because and I said this I said this
to him as well to Jamie because
um there weren't many people
that gave me
a smile when all I wanted to do was cry
so thanks a lot man oh my God I really
mean what the [__] no it's real though I
don't think you understand I mean as
this kid who's watching Mad TV and [__]
you know it's like
enough I didn't have anything like
literally nothing you know food stamps
and and and Welfare and just being
in a household that was just riddled
with such negativity and crime and it's
wild man so thanks a lot thanks for
making me laugh that's some real [__]
like you really I don't think you'll
ever actually understand
how much you as a person were like
medicine to me so thanks thank you I
don't know what to say psych no I'm just
kidding
that's true you know I um wow
wow anyway um well because you know you
do things I mean you don't know what
you're doing you're affecting or
whatever you're just showing up at a job
you got you're like I'll try my best and
this is you know what I mean but it's
like sometimes like I hear like The
Narrative of like the way he sees his
life and he's always like you know like
I've put stuff up my butt for a laugh
like and he has like shame around like
the crazy stunts maybe they pull them
they're just like wait but like you're
someone's medicine
when they were a child like yeah you
don't think of it that way but you don't
think of it that way at all you know and
when you're you know I'll be honest with
you when you were talking just now you
know I I do a thing where it's like I
want to find the joke or not you know I
mean and because it's uncomfortable to
listen to but yeah I heard every word
you said and I I felt it dude so um yeah
I am I'm except I'm not gonna turn into
a thing um thank you I did I did it for
you
thank you for the punchline yeah
it's like [__] yeah I was going to say
that yeah but my point is is that but
how does one because when people have
that kind of upbringing right generally
right their life turns a specific
Direction maybe a a life of crime or
drugs because my brother's sold drugs
they sold crack to our dad so my dad
would smoke crack and then they would
sell it to him and so you're right yeah
they they tend to sorry to interrupt you
but no you're not but it's funny because
what you were about to say is what so
many people have said to me how do you
not follow that same path how do you not
go down the path of shooting guns and
selling drugs and you know even as a
teenager I cook crack cocaine so it's
like going through that
um and making it out I don't know what
it is I can't explain it you know I
could say oh it's part common sense and
part god or the universe or whatever
um I don't know and I I think um
respectfully I don't say this in a weird
way you know a lot of people they follow
religion they have a religion and they
like to know what it is they believe
their faith they know if they do XYZ
that me personally my relationship like
I don't believe that God is a white guy
on a cloud or anything like that and I
don't discredit religion by any means
but there's a lot of people who feel
like almost the need to know you know
it's like if you know people with a
tinfoil hat are like the government's up
to something I gotta know I'm the type
of person that like man the government's
up to some [__] yeah sure they might be
watching us on our iPhones okay cool
check out my dick like whatever like I
don't need to know yeah so there's a
part of me where others were always like
how did you make it out how did you make
it out I'm like I don't know and I don't
need to know all I know is that I'm in a
position and so blessed to be here that
I'm going to use this to spread a
message of peace love and positivity and
that's it
I I'm beginning to think that it has
nothing to do with nature nurture and
all that kind of stuff or like even
genetic maybe not genetics but it's
genetic you're right genetics you know
yeah because
like look at an example Barack Obama
right raised by his mother dad wasn't
around biracial biracial right